- So welcome, everyone.
I just watched the movie,
"The Ice Cream Sellers".
I hope you've had a chance to watch it.
It's an absolutely fantastic,
really eye opening,
really unflinching view of
the Cox's Bazar refugees.
And I'm here today with
Sohel Rahman, the filmmaker,
to have a Q&A and discussion.
I'll ask him a few questions,
but hopefully we can
get a lot more questions
from the audience.
So to introduce myself,
I'm Neela Saldanha, and
I'm the Executive Director
of the Yale Research Initiative
on Innovation and Scale,
that's Y-RISE.
And the faculty director of Y-RISE
is Professor Mushfiq Mobarak
in the Economics Department.
At Y-RISE, we look at
advancing the science
of scaling development
and policy interventions.
And humanitarian issues such as refugee
and conflict areas is always important
because in some ways,
unlike regular poverty,
I shouldn't say regular,
but really about ongoing
and chronic poverty issues.
Humanitarian crisis can often
exacerbate what's going on.
As in the case of Covid-19,
the world goes out of gear.
We've seen that with any emergency,
so it's even worse when you
have a humanitarian crisis.
What I think is actually depressing
but also familiar about crises
such as the Rohingya crisis
is that it is also a chronic
longstanding problem.
We'll talk a little bit
about that in the Q&A.
It's my great pleasure
to welcome Sohel Rahman.
Sohel is an award-winning filmmaker,
writer and producer.
He's currently based in Lisbon, Portugal.
His films have been
screened internationally
in various film festivals and
universities around the world.
Sohel received the Best
Feature Documentary Film Award
from the South Asian Film
Festival of Montreal, Canada
in 2021 and from Tasveer South
Asian Film Festival, Seattle
in 2021 for this film,
"The Ice Cream Sellers".
He also received the Best Film Award
from Lusofona University, Lisbon in 2015
for his film, "A Passagem" (The Passage).
In the same year, he won
the Special Jury Award
at the Encontros International Cinema
de Vienna Film Festival in Portugal.
Born in Chittagong, Bangladesh,
Sohel's love of visual art,
literature and storytelling drew
him to film-making early in life.
He teaches film in different
universities and institutes
in Portugal and Bangladesh
as an invited filmmaker.
He's the director and chief organizer
of Mostra de Cinema sul
Asiatico, Lisbon, Portugal.
So welcome, Sohel.
It's really an honor to
have you here talking
about your film.
- Thank you so much, Neela.
It's an honor to have
me here and my presence
and screen my film here.
Thank you so much.
- Thank you.
And I know we have fewer
members of the audience here,
but I'd really like to
start with a question
around where is everybody
really coming from?
But if I ask you where you're coming from,
you're gonna say New Haven.
So really want to know first of all,
where are our members of the audience?
Where did you actually grow
up? What were your experiences?
So if you can put into the
Zoom chat we currently have,
which country you grew up in,
if there were multiple
countries you grew up in,
put all of them down.
I think it'll give us a
sense of what experiences
our audiences have  had because
our experiences inform
how we look at things,
like Rohingya, et cetera.
So I'd love to know where
you actually came from.
So put in your answers in the chat
and let's see what shows up in the map.
So I'm gonna start.
I will put my answer.
I grew up in India.
And I think, Sohel, you grew up in,
so you can see that's me.
Grew up in India.
You don't have to raise your hand.
Just put your answers down,
just type out your answers in the chat.
Shanghai. It's good to know.
Turkey.
Denmark.
U.S.A., New York State.
So it's good to know.
I think we've got people.
And the reason I think this is important
is because where we grew up
and where we spend our lives influences
and provides us a lens also
into the world, I think.
So it's nice to know that folks
have really come from all over the world.
And I'd really like to know also,
have you watched the movie yet?
Because if not, I think Sohel
can give a little bit of an introduction
to the movie and I really
hope you'll watch it.
I spent...
I didn't even realize
an hour and 15 minutes
and I had to sit in silence after that
for the next I think 10 or 15 minutes
because no matter how much
you read about something,
I think it's when you watch
the everyday lives of people
who are going through
that particular situation,
you can really sort of
understand what's happening.
So again, if you can
just let me know in the,
maybe just put it in the Q&A,
whether you've watched the movie,
the "Ice Cream Sellers".
Well, let me just actually share my screen
and let me.
This one.
Let me do this poll then.
Okay, so there are three.
Just type one, two or three.
Like have you watched the movie?
If you've seen the the whole movie,
if you've only partly seen the movie,
you started watching 10
minutes and then you stopped
or if you haven't watched it now.
Just put in one, two,
or three on the chat.
Great, Dean.
Yes, it was really eyeopening, I think.
So,
yeah, that's great.
So some of you watched it partly, I think.
Yeah, looks like people
have watched it, Sohel.
And even though this is
a relatively small group,
it's good to see.
Yeah, so it looks like a lot of you
have watched the movie.
It's not long for the ones who said partly
or those who say no.
It's just an hour and 15 minutes.
And I think it's
absolutely worth watching.
I didn't even do what I normally do,
which is to put this on 1.25
speed or one and a half speed
because I think it's really
not just the film itself,
but the silences and some of the scenes
that are worth actually
taking in and reflecting on.
So I actually hope that everybody
has actually sort of watched the movie
or ends up watching it as a
result of our discussion today
and questions that you
might have and so on.
So for those of you who
actually watched the movie,
what sort of, again,
you can put in the chat,
what sort of words would
you use to describe,
and this is, I think, Sohel
was looking for some feedback
on the movie.
So my quick question before
we start and I ask him,
what sort of words would you use
to describe the "Ice Cream Sellers"?
You can just put it in the chat,
four or five of you who
have watched the movie.
Yeah, I think that was true.
It was very moving.
I felt the same way.
And the other,
unfair.
That's very interesting
and maybe I'll call on you
to talk about that a little bit.
Just any words that come to mind.
I know a lot of words came to mind.
Not all of them can be
repeated because like you,
I found it unfair and
it made me angry a bit
to see the unfairness.
But any other words that
for those of you who watched
the movie and if someone said
it was a great experience.
Playful. That's interesting.
Yes, I think I got a
sense of that as well.
And maybe we'll probe a little bit
with Sohel in that candid.
Evocative, yes.
I think the games and
toys really led to that.
And so, it's kind of an
unusual combination, I agree,
with sort of the general sentiment here
that not only was it moving,
but it was also moving
because it was playful
and because of the games and toys.
So, in some ways,
and we talk a little bit about that,
what led Sohel to make this kind of movie
and this particular lens
on things that we have.
But, yeah, thank you very much.
And I'll sort of stop
sharing and get to...
I hope that was good and
you sort of saw a sense
of Sohel leaving a sense of
what the audience took away
from the movie, which is what
I took away from the movie,
this sort of sense of both
being moving and playful,
of being, astounded is
a good word, I think.
Astounded by both the resilience,
but the matter of factness
really came out to me as well,
which is that often when
people have suffered so much,
there is just no way to
describe the reaction
other than being completely
matter of fact about it.
And if you actually mute the
sound and you just listen
to them, you wouldn't think
that they were talking
about their husbands or their sons
or their daughters being
killed or raped or mutilated.
You'd just think they were
talking about everyday things.
And I don't know whether that was,
for me that was even more sort of moving
than if that had been drama.
But I want to come to
sort of this question
of what motivated you to make this film
and this particular angle
of using the children
and using those elements
of joy and playfulness
in the middle of this terrible,
portraying this atrocity, Sohel.
- Okay, thank you, Neela, for
giving me a chance to explain
and thank you all audience who
participated in the chatting
and also saying this feedback.
Is great to hear from all of you.
Well, first of all, when it's
started happening in 2017,
my mom was calling me all the time.
Every day was like,
"What's happening here in the Naf River?"
'Cause I'm from Chittagong,
and it's not far
from the refugee camp in Bangladesh.
It's a few hours from my
hometown to the refugee camp.
And all of our people from the country,
Bangladeshi people,
they went there to help
Whatever they had, they extended help
like whoever needed some water
or some food or anything,
whatever they had.
And my mom was saying like,
"Oh, what are you doing?
You have to do something for them."
And I felt like, yeah,
I have to do something
in what I can do.
So I was following up the
news, what's really happening,
and one picture just touched my heart.
It just broke my heart.
A mother, she was carrying
two children on her shoulder
and running fast towards the border.
So it's like, my mother
doesn't belong to the Rohingya,
but what would have
happen if she if she did?
Then I just imagine a
situation that it is my mom
and carrying me and my siblings
and also running towards the border.
And I can't imagine that.
I just felt like, okay,
so I have to do something
as a human, as a filmmaker.
So I flew from Lisbon to Chittagong,
and I went to that refugee
camp and started filming.
So first of all, I was
like a little bit lost
because there's too much for someone
to endure all those happening,
all those suffering.
Or you see the wounded people, women,
and they cry and are traumatized.
They almost lost
everything, even the sense
and normal sensibility.
So when they were talking,
they feel like talking.
They were narrating,
they were describing a killing
like they have breakfast.
They're talking about the breakfast,
they're talking something
like usual things.
I saw this, they lost this.
Then I was kind of distracted
with the storytelling
because I cannot just shoot randomly.
So I need a story to tell.
And I just felt like, no,
I have to tell this story
because I have this access
and I know the dialect,
what they speak and is very
essential for a filmmaker
when you go there, and you
cannot just tell their story
if you don't have the access,
if you don't have the same
language or same empathy
or the suffering or pain.
And in that case,
first couple of days I
spend for my research like,
okay, what would be my film?
What would be my story?
And I didn't want to make a
conventional refugee film.
I know that there are a lot of film
and everybody understands,
okay, it's the cry, it's the suffering.
So what else do we need?
And I just decided,
okay, my team of the film
would be something like
after this massive massacre,
bloodshed, after all this
losing their country,
their homeland, their loved one.
So a community, how they can
really survive as a human.
So I just saw everywhere
there are children,
children, children, children,
and on every street of
this tiny little path,
you see children.
Children are children wherever they are.
Is still, they have this
irreplaceable spirit,
laughter, happiness.
Even though there is
weakness, they saw everything,
but still they have
this spirit of children
and they are trying to
make their childhood.
They're trying to create
their own childhood
wherever they are.
And then I was like, okay,
so maybe it would be nice
to have the perspective
through the like a post genocide period
through the eyes of children.
How?
Because those children, they
are hope, they are dream.
They are the power for this community.
That's what I felt.
Then I started like,
okay, this is the story.
Then I needed to find out someone
to encourage, to guide me,
to lead the storyline,
the spine of the story.
Then through several encounter,
I found Ayas and Asia,
these little siblings.
And I asked them, "What are you doing?"
And, "Having ice cream."
Then, "Oh, okay, so you
are selling ice cream?
Why are you selling ice cream?"
"Because we need to make money."
"Why do you need to make money."
Then they said, "Okay, I have
to give this money to my mom."
"And your mom, what she's
going to do with this money?"
"Because our father is
in prison in Myanmar
and if we send some bribe money
to the officials in Myanmar
in prison so that our
father can get released."
So this is their hope and
they keep trying everyday.
This is such a huge work. It's very hard.
Even I was with my camera.
And I was with my camera,
I was getting tired.
It's so dusty, so hot.
The camp is a never ending village.
You keep walking and you just need to,
and I was amazed.
I was like, oh, my god, how
the power these teach us.
They are incredible, those.
- [Neela] Right.
- So that just moved me.
And then I choose these
children to go on with this
and I asked them if they allow me to film.
And I said, you don't have to do anything.
You just let me know to
film you, to follow you.
That's it, I need.
So every day, the goal,
I go with them and they stop one door,
another door, I stop and
I face several people
and I encounter those people
and they tell me their story.
There are several testimonies.
I didn't put everything in the film.
And I tried.
It is very hard also in
the post-production time
because which one is more important?
I have to make a balance
because there's so heavy things
and I can't deal with heaviness.
I needed to make it a bit lighter.
And I see this.
On one hand, we have
harrowing tale of parents.
On the other hand, the children,
their laughter, their joy.
So that's what...
Yeah, sorry.
- That's fantastic.
I just wanna call attention
to one thing that you said,
which I think is so true.
So this movie hit particularly hard for me
because in a previous life,
I worked with Unilever,
which sells ice creams,
Kwality Wall's one of the brands.
And I was actually responsible
for ice cream sales
in a part of North India.
And I think what you
said is completely true
about it's very hard work.
One of the things that I
was just thinking about
is also, if you don't sell
the ice creams enough,
they melt.
So this is not a product
like selling chips
or selling something which
will last for the next day.
You have to sell what you started
at the beginning of the
day by the end of the day
otherwise it's useless.
And I'm sure the person that
they are buying the ice creams
from will judge them if
they have unsold ice cream.
So it's also very...
Holding that box, I was really wondering
how the little boy was actually
sort of holding the box
and going around so easily.
It's heavy and it's insulated
and it's very hard work
and yet they seem to do
it very matter of factly.
And I do think that what
you've said came through
very clearly in terms of the joyfulness
and the playfulness contrasted
with the subject being so heavy.
And I noticed that you used
that in a number of places.
But before that, there was
a very interesting question
on CC Young, which is, "Hi, Sohel.
Your documentary's really powerful?
Can you give us a bit of
background about the meaning
of ice cream and ice in the area
where you shot the documentary?"
Especially there was a lot of imagery
about people taking baths,
bucket baths, washing
their bodies with water.
So was there something
there that connected it
or how did you get on the story
of the kids selling ice cream?
We saw a lot of other vendors.
Someone was selling earrings,
someone was selling balloons.
Of course, they're adult vendors.
But how did you get into?
Was there anything specific
about the ice cream
or it was just one of those?
- Well, this ice, when I
was working, I was filming.
Thanks for the question.
Is a very interesting question
and I would love to talk about
this because it was very hot
and they don't have any
power, any electricity
fridge and any cold water.
And I was sweating even me
when I was with the camera
and everybody is very,
the shelter of the...
Is not a home, but the
shelter of the refugee camp
in the camp.
So it's very dusty and hot.
So they don't have any
cold water or anything.
Even also that they're
not surrounded by trees
or green things.
Now it's growing these days.
But when I was filming, it
was right after the genocide.
It's very new and very fresh.
That time, I just felt
like, wow, this ice cream,
these kids, they are not
just selling ice cream.
They are putting a little
piece of cold water.
Is like a piece giving them
peace in that burning fire.
So you give a little water.
They needed something.
That's why these kids bringing the hope
through this ice cream.
They have nothing, but
they offer you something
and that's a piece of ice cream.
But that's a metaphor, a big,
that box they holds on the shoulder,
they hold their lives there.
Like taking that,
that's moved me a lot.
So I also, I tried several
title for the film,
but then I was like, no,
I wanted to make it simple
and short.
So I choose "Ice Cream Sellers"
as a title of the film.
- [Neela] Yeah. And-
- And I think that's your film.
It's simple on the surface,
but it's got a lot of layers
once you sort of unpeel
the surface.
It seems like a simple thing.
And I did notice that at
the beginning of the film
you have this very lush sort of green,
as they're fleeing, I think there's
a shorter very lush green fields.
And then when I saw the
the camp, you're right,
it's very dusty.
In fact, halfway through I realize
there's not even a
single tree in this camp.
It's just all like dust
and it's brown big.
And it just brought me to mind of how,
it's not just about
being in a refugee camp,
which is hard enough,
but it's where you actually are
to be just stripped off nature
and in such a difficult
situation must just add
to the difficulties.
One thing I noticed, Sohel, in the movie
which really struck me was that
in this temporary area
of temporary living,
people maintained such good rules.
So halfway through, I was wondering,
there are two little
kids taking ice creams.
Anyone can just sort of snatch
their ice cream box, right?
Or not pay for the ice creams.
And yet every transaction, people haggle.
They bargain in any market.
The kid says, "I wanna get
my profit if I sell so many."
It was a very normal interaction.
It wasn't what we often think
about in conflict situations,
which is that people will lose all sense
of what day to day interactions look like.
So it looked like a
normal market transaction
if you hadn't told me that
it was in a refugee camp.
Can you say something from
your experience with filming
in terms of this kind of observation
in terms of rules of the
camp or rules of interaction
during this time of...
Was it surprising?
Was it, no, actually.
It's not surprising because when a group
of people get together and
they've been living somewhere
for five years, maybe they
need to have certain rules,
otherwise the whole thing
would be generated into chaos.
But what was surprising to you
about the situation that you
were not expecting when you
went into making the film?
- There are lots of things.
And I think every day when
I go to the camp to shoot,
and it's because most
of the people, I mean,
they don't have any
cash money and the rice
that they receive from the
international aid organization,
so they get it every day
or in a week or somehow
and they have this collection of rice.
But that's also important
and they are waiting.
They have nothing to do, just traumatized.
That's like exhausted with
their weight of trauma
and then they exchange this with the rice.
But on one side, they lost everything.
And there are sensibility,
there are sympathy.
Is fluctuated.
It's like, okay, I saw everything,
all the horrible things happened to me.
Before my eyes, I saw my son got killed.
I saw so many,
how come I can survive anymore?
They lost the normal sensibility.
So every day when I go
to the camp to film,
then I see, I beg, I can't sleep anymore,
especially the mother who
was at the end you saw
she was crying.
Like she couldn't control anymore
and she was hugging the tree.
And she thought I look
like I resemble her son.
And it was very heartbreaking.
I couldn't really control.
Even my camera, I was asking myself,
should I roll my camera or
should I just give her a hug?
I wanted to give her a hug.
But also there is a cultural problem.
Like you cannot hug a woman
in that corner of the world
somehow if you are a stranger.
But it's like, it feels
my heart was burning
when I was encountering
and was interviewing her.
It's not an interview,
I just ask her what's the story?
And also every day I meet them.
I didn't keep a profile as a filmmaker.
I went there, I didn't
use any crew member.
I was alone with a little
camera with a Canon 5D Mark 2
and I put a microphone on the camera.
So people are not afraid
and they don't have any
pressure to impress me
to like, okay, this is the
fourth television for the film.
No.
So it was very natural and I
wanted to go under the surface.
I wanted to feel their pain in my camera
and also personally.
And it's shocking every day.
I couldn't sleep for a long time
and I was also having tough time.
Then it was those kids
that were a massive source
of inspiration for me.
And I saw, I learned from
them, wow, they are doing this
and I have to do, I have to keep going.
Even in life we have so
many trouble happens.
But look at these kids,
they have nothing but
there is still laughing,
there is still moving forward.
So I get inspired out of their work,
how they work, how they
live there every day.
And there are several characters.
One guy who was selling,
he was selling something,
I think vegetables and he sold everything
and he tried to buy some
balloons for his kids
and he couldn't afford that.
He tried to bargain something
and he couldn't afford.
And the balloon sellers,
they're also tough 'cause
they're also selling balloons
and also, they have to
buy it with the money.
They don't have enough money
to be kind to this guy.
And they're also very harsh
and they're just like, "No,
we cannot make it for you."
And they are gone and
this guy is just waiting
and just looking to the balloon.
I was like, oh my god.
And he came and he was counting the money.
And so, every day there are other women
who was saying how they
got raped, their wounds.
But it is too much for the audience,
for international audience to show this.
But personally, it was
very shocking for me.
- Yeah, and it's interesting that you say
it's too much for the
international audience
to be shown, right?
Because it is actually reality.
And here we are actually saying,
well, reality might be
too harsh for those of us
who are fortunate and lucky
to escape that reality.
So in some ways, it's actually
worse than I hear you saying,
it's much, much worse
than what can be shown
and what has been shown.
And I do wanna make a point
about what you talked about,
which is the resilience.
I noticed that scene as
well and it was striking
for two reasons.
One is, as you said, like a
normal market transaction,
you might work very hard and then
not be able to afford something, right?
We see this issue with
deprivation all the time.
Those of us who are fortunate enough,
we still feel deprived with,
I can't afford this particular thing.
But it's even worse.
And it's probably even more exacerbated
in a conflict and humanitarian situation
because you've really lost everything.
And time and time again,
there were people in the film who talked
about how much they had
lost and really that.
And there was the scene
I think right after that
where the person says,
"We should just buy
balloons for the children
because they should just be happy."
And I think that's really
interesting because
in normal situations we teach
children to wait for things
and to sort of have self control.
But in this situation,
how can you really deny whatever
little happiness you get
when life is uncertain?
I do think there was
another scene similarly
where someone said,
"We just pretend we are
on holiday in this camp
because we don't want to
believe that this is reality."
And it's really,
there is a lot of work
to be done, I think,
to understand mental health consequences
and how people cope with
this kind of situation
because it's not just a situation of loss,
it's a situation of uncertainty.
And we know that in times of uncertainty,
people cope in very different ways.
So just as we are discussing
what is it that we need
to know, I think that certainly
there were a few places
that I felt, oh, we
should really understand
what the consequences of
being in the camp are,
the uncertainty sort of
idea that I lost something.
At the end of the movie,
you talked about sort of
the current situation.
When exactly did you film this?
Because you talked about
Covid 19 actually impacting
the situation.
Can you talk a little bit about that
and if you've gone back or
heard anything since then,
what the situation has been like?
- Okay, so I filmed
right after the genocide
when they're coming.
So it was in 2017.
So I kept in touch, but after filming,
I was there for three months
then I came back to Portugal
and I was editing.
But in my postproduction
time, I had to put this,
okay, the latter situation
was really happening
and then we see the trial
in the International Court
of Justice, ICJ in the Hague,
that also this Covid happening.
Then there was no hope.
And I was still in contact
with them. What's happening?
Your father is back?
- "No."
- And there there is no hope.
And slowly they were
getting out of the headline
and they are no more headline
and then nobody is talking about that.
So now is terrible.
It's also hard for me to have the access
because there is no mobile phone,
no network inside the camp.
So I couldn't really continue
to keep in touch with them.
But I know some of my
friends who are working there
and also some of the
refugee Rohingya people.
So I'm in touch with them
and I'm asking what's really happening
and they keep me updated
about the situation,
which is really is also
shocking because every day
is getting less.
They don't have any more education,
right of education.
So they don't really.
Before there was some sort of education
and now it's getting more worse.
And so, the aid is getting less every day
that there is no education.
And also that the people, they
are getting more desperate.
So they are escaping from
the camp by illegal ways.
So sometimes, we see the news
and they died in the river
because they were trying to escape it,
they were trying to go somewhere Indonesia
or Malaysia or India and it's horrible.
And they know that what's
really consequences coming
for in their life, but they don't care.
And they said like, "What
else do we have to do?"
'Cause when I was filming,
I couldn't put every
statement, every testimony,
but there were people who
are dreaming that one day
we go back and I get
married, one day we go.
The children were there saying,
"What's happening with the mango trees?"
And that's another shocking scene for me.
When the children, they were...
I was filming something else
and suddenly I saw them,
they're having this,
the situation is, they had hope.
Even after the genocide when they came
and they were still
expecting they will go back,
international community will help
to secure their basic human rights
and also citizenship
rights to go back there,
and before the repatriation.
Sometimes there was something like,
one time, I remember through the UN,
they tried to make a repatriation
for a small amount of people,
but they said, "We prefer
to get buried with funeral
rather than just going there,
getting killed and get buried.
And if we stay here, we get funeral.
If you go there, we would not get there."
So that's very,
they care about these things.
And the things, what's
happening in Myanmar right now
also not very pleasing and is
also still ongoing genocide.
Yesterday I saw a video
clip from a Rohingya person.
He was also saying like,
"Look, we are not happy.
We are in here stuck
in the Maungdaw region
in the Rakhine State and is
still another ongoing genocide."
So international community, he was asking
to give some attention to
them and try to help them.
- Yeah, and I do want to add here
that neither Sohel nor I are experts
in international humanitarian law,
but on March 21st, 2022,
following a rigorous factual
and legal analysis, the Secretary of State
of the United States determined
that members of the Burmese
military committed genocide
and crimes against
humanity against Rohingya.
And the United States has
concluded only seven other times
since the Holocaust
genocide was committed.
So this determination was the eighth.
So there are various terms that are used
and various ways to classify
atrocities against humanity.
But just wanted to put that out there.
I think one of the related
questions Paul Sarno asked is,
"Do the camp residents
know about the lawsuit
before the ICJ and all the other suits?
What are they aware of
taking from Paul's question?
What are they actually aware
of what the outside world is,
is thinking or doing in this regard?"
- Well, some people know,
some people following that,
but most of the people that
they don't have proper education
or academic education for a long time.
Because it is a slow poisoning.
For a long time when
the Myanmar government
had taken out the citizenship right
and they didn't have access to the school,
maybe they finish primary
school or elementary school,
then they didn't have
access to the university,
so they couldn't really
continue their education.
So what's really happening,
most of them are either
fishermen or just farmer
or doing something else
to make their living.
And now is more.
They don't have that fresh air anymore.
They are like in an open air prison.
And it is different circumstances
and they are not very aware
like in terms of general Rohingya.
But there are some people who
are connected with network
or somehow they are
they working for an NGO.
So they have sort of knowledge,
what's really happening about the lawsuit
and with the the ICJ and
sometimes they celebrate
that The Gambia was helping,
that The Gambia was standing for them.
So it goes viral in the refugee camp.
So everybody knows that,
but not really like knowing
about law and the rights,
not everybody because, yeah.
I can't say about everybody,
but maybe there are some changes now.
- Yeah.
No, and if any of the audience members
has much more in depth
knowledge of humanitarian
or international law,
please feel free to actually
share that knowledge
on the chat.
Paul also asked a related, I
think quite difficult question,
which is it's clear that it's
unlikely they will be able
to go back to Myanmar.
If that is correct, which
countries do you think
that they will go go?
Or do we have any idea?
And just to put this in perspective,
the statistic that actually
shocked me was to learn
that there were almost a million refugees.
And I looked at the population
of New Haven, Connecticut,
where Yale Universities
are at 130,000 people
in all of New Haven.
So this is kind of like
eight times the population
of New Haven.
And New Haven is the
third largest city or town
in Connecticut in one of the states.
So that just puts into
perspective just how big this,
it's not a question of
a few hundred refugees.
And I think very similar to
other long longstanding camps,
that is Dadaab, et cetera.
The question I think is,
where would they go, right?
I understand they've been effectively,
they're stateless in that sense.
They're not recognized as citizens.
I think the big question is,
is there any sort of
update or understanding
or negotiation about where they would go?
- Okay, so I just followed some news
and there was a foreign
minister of Bangladesh
who was trying to talk
with China, with India,
because this is also going
to be a regional threat.
What is happening?
This refugee youngsters,
they are growing up
and there is lots of children of,
I think it's 30,000 children every year.
I forgot the exact number,
but it's something like that.
And so, what's really happening?
And is going to be,
if you're not providing education,
if you're not providing
any basic human rights
and everything is getting
like more smaller,
more worse, then they
would get more desperate.
And they will be used by other criminals,
for example, especially for the drugs.
And that area is very
famous for the drugs dealing
because of the river, because of the sea.
And there was something happening,
and it is not just for the Bangladesh,
but also is a regional threat
for India, for Myanmar,
for Bangladesh, for Thailand,
for other countries who
are sharing the same area.
And that's why they have
like all the government,
they should really take
the necessary steps
or very like useful
things, not just talking.
And last on 25th or 24th of August,
I was sharing a panel with a conversation
with the foreign minister of Malaysia.
He also said they are very
welcoming to Rohingya refugee,
but already they have some people there,
the Rohingya community,
a big community of Rohingya.
They're living in Malaysia.
So far, what I talk to the...
Also in India, also in Indonesia,
there are few numbers
and I know some people
who are living in the U.S.
but not that big amount.
It's not that effective.
- Yeah.
- What concern?
If that is correct,
to what countries do
you think they will go?
They still prefer to go to Myanmar.
They are just not refugees.
They are a group of people
with past, with honor,
with culture.
And now they lost everything.
And there there are still saying that.
The people there, there are
people who are saying like,
"We are just socializing.
We feel like we have to feel
like we are on holiday."
That guy after the interview,
he was full of tears because he said,
"I had too many Honda, motor bikes,
and I was a very rich person,
I was a very respected person.
Now I have nothing to do.
I lost everything.
- And I think...
- Yeah.
- Sorry, I didn't mean to interrupt you,
but I just wanted to say that
I don't think we often realize
that refugees in humanitarian
camps can't work.
They're not allowed to work.
So this is not like a migration
scenario where people go
to another country and they can work.
Even now I think the
government is deciding
whether they can work
and I think you referred
to it in the drug violence.
And again, the way people
are coping with it is to say,
we are here on a holiday,
we are socializing.
But in addition to income,
there's also a loss of identity
if people get a lot of
their meaning in life
from working.
And if they just can't work,
they can obviously get
desperate for income,
but also a lot of their
sense of what it means
to be a useful person in society
because that's the way we've always talked
about people, right?
That you should work for a living.
And when you can't do that,
there are a lot of issues that I think
will come to the fore.
You're completely right
in terms of these effects
of violence and other sort of abuses
because people are just
not allowed to work.
I mean, imagine if any
of us were told tomorrow,
I think we'd be happy
for maybe a day or two
and then we'd start getting restless.
So imagine when you're told
for long periods of time
that your status is so uncertain,
you're not allowed to work.
So, yeah, I think when I
heard that person talking,
you could very clearly
see that he wasn't saying
it very joyfully.
He was almost saying it in
a very resigned fashion.
What can we do? We can socialize here.
I think a good question that comes up is,
and this is a tricky question, right,
because, again, this is very
different from chronic poverty
in that people need to know
information about their rights.
And a lot of people in the documentary
also talked about their rights.
They talked about getting
back their rights.
So did the NGOs that help in the Rohingya
and the camps disseminate
information about rights
or do they support them
on more of the healthcare
and other basic necessities?
Do you see more of the
humanitarian agencies
have set up and there are different areas
that they help in
education and healthcare?
Is there a way that people are
educated about their rights?
So you think that's not
yet happening in the camps?
- Well, so far, I know
with my little knowledge,
I think there are some organizations
who are working for that.
But this is not really enough for this.
Formally, schools are closed,
so there is no even school.
So it is getting,
because Bangladesh has
this, what I learned,
they're saying like, is a refugee camp.
We can't give them like a home,
like giving the education and everything.
So they will stay longer.
They would not go back home.
So that's what I realized
through the different kind
of explanation from a different corner.
But what I feel is very important
to let them know their basic rights,
information about health,
about the birth control
because is also like really happening.
And they said, like if God creates,
there are also misconceptions
because of their lack of knowledge,
they depend on something
like spiritual power,
something like gods.
Mostly they are devoted to the religion,
but at the same time,
they have no any kind of material
or any other education.
Please, don't get offended, other people.
I'm not against religion,
but I'm saying that
they have a saying that,
"Oh, okay, if God creates the children,
God will take care of them."
But at the end of the day, you have to go,
you have to ask for
food for your children.
They have misconception
about so many things,
about way of living, about their health,
the other system, other disease.
And I think, yeah, of
course the government,
Bangladesh government at the same time,
some other NGO or the organization,
they should take care of it more.
- Sorry, I was on mute.
There's a good point to think about,
which is that it's not just
about providing the health
and the basic necessities, but, again,
as we talked about work,
work is not just about
the money that you get,
it's also your chance to be
a sort of productive member
of the society.
So it contributes to your identity.
Similarly, it's not only
about giving people healthcare
and basic necessities,
but also telling people
about their rights, right?
Treating them like equal human beings
and really sort of
recognizing their dignity
even in this situation.
So it's really important.
Sometimes we can forget
that when we are so...
All of us who are in service,
of course, we'll forget it
because we think, oh, if
we give give people help,
then that's enough.
But we forget that people are people,
we are full human beings.
We want our dignity to be
affirmed in whatever we do.
And that is the ability to work,
the ability to have freedom,
to move, to know our rights,
to fight for our rights.
And however, people might say,
"Well, why don't you compromise or adjust?
If I feel very strongly,
I should be allowed to express that."
So I think that came up a little bit
because I was surprised.
Not surprised, but I think
it was really reflective
that despite all of what they've seen,
they still talked about,
"We want our rights.
We want to go back and we want our rights,
otherwise there's no point in going back."
So they were not prepared to
just go back just like that.
They said, "Only if our full
rights are restored to us."
CC had a question about
what the mother was doing
while the kids sold ice cream.
Do you know for the kids who were selling?
- Age.
- She mentioned a younger child.
Was there a younger child also?
I don't think we saw the younger child,
but you mentioned towards
the end, I wasn't sure.
- Okay.
So I was also wondering
what she was really doing
and then I asked her,
but she said she takes
care of them and she tried
to get some work, but
she didn't get any work.
So she completely depends on income
of her kids earning every day.
And she takes care of other children.
You see like one, two, three, four.
Four of them and she
has more kids, two more.
- Yeah. And they are not there.
So, yeah, I mean, is most of
the women, they are like that.
- And I think again, it's another thing
when we talk about
setting up refugee camps.
It's not as simple as
giving people some housing
and giving them some food.
What happens is societal inequalities,
sort of also the same
thing happens, right?
So if women have not been
used to sort of earning
their own living or
doing something or people
are not used to employing them,
they're not going to employ them
just because it's now a refugee camp.
So we've gotta think about,
what were they doing before?
What are people's social
norms about what women can
and can't do and what needs to be done?
And in this context, I
wanna say that at Y-RISE,
we are conducting some
research in Cox's Bazar
with the World Bank
and other institutions.
And one of the things is
to understand violence
against women.
Understand, someone talked about,
I think she should talked
about how inequalities
impact children's life.
I think we are trying to understand
how such conditions impact things
like violence against women,
which is, is it worse?
Is it better because everyone's
now in a shared situation?
Is it worse because there's
so much frustration?
Has it become worse as people
are there for a longer time?
Because if you have to do...
Is it different from
violence against women
in chronic poverty situations
or there's something
about this particular
situation that's different
because only if we understand that,
we can understand what's happening.
I do wanna encourage the audience
to post any more questions in the Q&A.
And also maybe in terms of at
least my final question maybe
to Sohel, but also to
the audience, which is,
as a filmmaker, what's their expectation
of centers of learning like Yale
and the university can actually
do in this giant problem?
We are not governments and we are not NGOs
who are directly going to be there,
but there is a role that
universities can actually play
in in maybe getting attention
to these atrocities.
What do you see as sort of the role?
And very similar, I guess,
what's your role as a
filmmaker in highlighting
some of these things so that
others have awareness of it?
- Okay, so let's see if
there is some audience
that says something.
I would love some audience reactions.
What do you think is the role
of universities like Yale
in terms of this?
You can put it in the Q&A
and I'll just pick it up
from there,
but what do you think is
the role of universities
in humanitarian crises like this?
What can we do?
- I can't tell you like
what you should do,
but I can tell you my expectation.
- Yes.
- Maybe you are the right person.
What you can do,
you can tell about this from
the university perspective
or from the academic perspective.
But like if you go with the anthropology,
like Malinowski went for the field work,
so he brought something we didn't know,
but then we started.
That from this amateur anthropology,
then it breaks and this.
But I'm saying,
kind of a university, a
center, a research center,
a university, if they talk about this,
it means a lot for them.
For example, right now,
there are people engagement?
We are talking, you are talking.
So is already a lot for these,
one of the most persecuted
communities in the world.
Almost international community
has forgotten about them.
And now at university,
one of the top most
university in the world, Yale,
and I'm really grateful and thankful
to you to the university.
They invited my film and
screening for the big audience,
especially for the academic world.
And I think it has a significant impact,
especially for making that awareness
and also it is for the future
and future people will know that
and it'll help to prevent another genocide
in another corner of the world.
If we have some research,
why it's happening, what should we do?
And some suggestion, some
writing, some film, more films,
more reviews, more things.
So I think everybody, whatever we have,
the ability, we should talk about this.
We should go for this,
we should do anything.
So that's what I feel.
As a film maker, maybe I'm not,
I just tried a little contribution.
But what I'd be happy to see some day,
that's there are lots of people that said,
"Wow, this is something
what we needed to see.
And in France, it was in
person screening in France
in Toulouse when I screened
the film and some people
had to leave because they couldn't digest,
they couldn't continue because
it's too much for them.
And then some people just came to me
and just gave me a hug and
then started crying and saying,
"Oh my God, we didn't have
any idea what's happening
in that corner of the world.
We just saw some news and that's it."
So because the medium like
newspaper or the television
or journalistic work,
I appreciate lots of great journalists.
They went there.
They did great journalism,
their picture, they portrayed
the sufferings and everything.
But still they have
somehow they are not free.
There is always like editorial
policy of the newspaper,
always a policy.
So university in terms of university,
they have this freedom of research.
They have this freedom
of raising the voice
in an authentic way honest and genuinely.
And then, I think the university
are more in university.
I'm so grateful to some
other universities.
They also invited me.
Almost now 15 universities
around the world,
they invited me with this film.
And I'm looking forward to the U.S. trip
where I'm going to screen my film in UCLA,
NYU and UC Berkeley.
And there are lots of
universities we are talking
like everyday.
So that's what I, as a
filmmaker, with this film,
I would like to tell this story
to the world and to feel it,
not just giving the information
but to feel and to fly
with this pain.
That's what I want.
- And I think you-
- To be part of the journey.
- [Neela] Thank you.
I think that there is one more question.
I just wanna make a note
about the role of university.
So we talked a little bit
about the label of genocide
and when that label is applied
and when it's not applied.
And it might just seem that,
oh, we are sitting here
in uncomfortable studies
and libraries and universities
and offices and deciding
whether to call something.
But I think labels provide
legitimacy and universities
do the same thing,
which I hear you saying.
They provide a platform,
they provide a legitimacy
to say this is real,
this is important,
this is something we
should pay attention to.
And I think that makes a lot in terms
of moving world opinion forward.
I also think your point
about freedom of research
is extremely important.
Universities have freedom
to research things
that might be uncomfortable but need
to be actually revealed.
So it's a very, I think important
and quite all inspiring
responsibility that we do have
as a university.
You've made the film,
you've really touched
the hearts of people.
You brought out the
reality as a filmmaker,
you've made this reality vivid to people.
Also universities are engaged
in teaching young people.
I think, what do we do to
avoid the next such atrocity?
What have we learned?
And I think in the light of discussions
about the liberal arts
and learning from history,
I think it really is important
to think about the role
of centers of learning
in something about this.
And there's one more question actually
that we had about the film from CC.
So I noticed that you
only shoot the upper body
of the man who lost his legs.
It seems that you don't
want to sell miseries.
And you talked a little bit about it.
Can you tell us a bit
about your thinking process
of making that shot?
And even I realized that and I was like,
wait a minute, he doesn't
have, his legs were shot.
I mean, from the angle
that you've shot him,
he looks actually quite
healthy and very well to do.
Can you tell us a little bit
about the thinking process
in terms of making the shot?
- Well, there are several shots like that.
And then, I always try
to treat it with respect,
with compassion, with respect.
And I really felt it.
It's not just for the cinematic journey,
but also as a person.
And I didn't, as I'm saying,
even I was having problem
if I should put the mother crying,
then finally I choose
to keep it in the film.
And there are other more horrible shots,
like really, it's too much that way
for the international audience.
Maybe the people who already saw there,
is usual for them and for
even some people who will say,
"Oh, this is nothing."
If they see my film, they will say,
"Oh, this is nothing,"
in terms of what's really
happening to them."
So I tried to have these people,
and in my framing, I was
following mostly observational.
And then I'm grateful to all those people
who allowed me to film them.
And I also didn't really
want to embarrass them
in terms of doing something.
And I didn't want to take disadvantages.
Maybe in cinematic way, it could be great,
but I left some shots
because it doesn't work
in terms of ethics, in terms of aesthetic.
So I tried to make like that way.
And then of course, as I'm saying,
it's a very tough and hard work.
It is very dark.
At the same time, it's
a pain, it's a tragedy,
it's a loss.
Then I'm like, how can I deal it?
For long time,
it took long time in terms of editing,
but also in terms of when
I was filming every day.
And I try to be very respectful
and passionate to them
and they understand it because,
if you see all the people
who are talking to the camera
or talking to me, you see their eyes.
And those eyes, they can't
lie if you see their eyes.
So then I tried to make
these eyes to the audience
to see their eyes.
I was reading a review,
an article from the Myanmar
perspective, and they said,
"Oh, they're lying.
Those people are lying.
Those are just a lie,
they're a false statement."
And then I was really like,
"No, come on. How come these
people can lie with me?
And they're with full of
tears with that old man,
the old man who had like two
men who were sitting together.
the beard man
He looks like...
I lost my father.
I found like he's another father of me.
And when he was talking,
he lost everything.
But the way,
the choice of his words, intonation
and everything was so
respectful, so humble.
And also it shows his personality.
And he lost everything.
But he still, the guy is quite controlled.
And I was really amazed. Oh my God!
These people,
how they can bear this wound inside them.
- No, it's a great point you raised
about how do you depict suffering
without sort of exploiting
people suffering.
There's been a lot of
backlash in the NGO world
around what is called poverty porn,
which is depicting people
in extreme suffering.
And it really is a difficult choice.
On the one hand, you do want to show that.
You don't want to sugarcoat reality.
But on the other hand,
both from the perspective of
sort of keeping people's agency
and also what Chimamanda Ngozi Adichie
of "The Danger of a Single Story".
These people are people
who have fled their homes
and they are now refugees in a camp.
But that's not only who they are.
They're also children.
They're also ice cream sellers.
They're also balloon sellers.
So I think you've done a great job in sort
of not just focusing on only
all of the suffering or trying
to exploit that.
I think it's a very fine
line that then you filmed,
so I thought that was very well done.
That was-
- Thank you, Neela.
Thank you.
- And yes,
as Zeid Ra'ad said, the
role of the university
with the help of filmmakers
is to show what is happening,
to document what is actually happening.
But to document it, as I said,
not just in a way that shows
only one story or one part,
it's all only suffering,
but to show the full reality
of what is happening, right?
How human beings cope in such
situations, the good, the bad,
so that we can have sort
of a better response.
I'm gonna throw it open if
there are other questions
that our audience has or comments,
and then maybe ask your final
sort of questions, Sohel,
in terms of anything else
that you would like to say,
given that you have this time,
and this will be shown not
just to the audience right now,
but to the broader audience.
I think Kathy had a
question, which is, oh, yes,
this was an interesting one.
Have you been able to screen
the film at the camp itself?
Were you able to go back and share?
And also my add-on question to that is,
have you been able to share
the responses to the film
with the people who were in the film?
- Yeah.
- Well, unfortunately, not yet,
but I would love to do that and tried.
And now next year I'm planning to go there
and to screen the film and
maybe I will follow up.
I will make another film.
What's really happening
after the five years,
Where is Ayas and Asia?
And I have to find them
because I lost their track
since they're mobile because
our only medium was mobile,
so I was getting touch
and then I lost them.
Now I would really love
to show the film to them
and also having the feedback,
what they really love.
But what I can tell you,
when I was filming every day,
and then at the end of the day,
that all the kids, they
became like my friends
and they follow me.
And then I was showing
them from my camera,
like, "Hey, look how you look like."
And they'll, "Oh, show me. Show me more.
Oh, good."
So it's funny, it's
pleasing and it's so nice.
I can't forget that memory.
- That's great.
And I hope you have a chance
to actually show this more widely
even to those who are
actually in the camp.
I think another question
that was asked was,
as documentary filmmaker,
and I think this is a little
bit of what we are discussing,
like how do you balance
the telling of the stories
while trying to be considerate
of not bringing out any trauma?
So we talked about not exploiting people,
but also just having
people relate their trauma
can be triggering for them.
I think of the mother who lost her son
and the child who was
talking about how things
would be better when his father was back.
So how do you deal with the
situation of asking people
to recount their trauma,
but also sort of playing
that balancing role
with making sure that you don't
bring out any more trauma?
- So it's a very significant question.
That's how I'm trying to evolve.
I'm trying to improve
myself as a filmmaker.
It's not just with the Rohingya,
but if you look my other works,
like I did with the two
Portuguese shepard ladies
with shepard women, they
are 85 and 87 years old.
They work in the middle of nowhere.
I'm a guy from Bangladesh
and they have never heard
about the country and
they have no idea where
is Bangladeshi.
It's something like that for
them is a different planet,
like a moon or sun or something like that.
So they have a tragedy.
The women, the shepherd lady, Dalina,
I call her grandma.
And she lost her husband,
he was also a shepherd,
by a car crash.
And the guy who made
the car crash crashed,
he is asking money for
the damage of his car.
It's such a trauma.
And she moved from one
city to other city to work
and all this.
She was living with her husband
and they were okay with shepherd,
with the animals and everything,
but then she has to carry this
trauma, losing her husband.
And then is another pain that someone
is knocking the door asking the money
for the damage of his car.
I asked like, okay, I
know this is the film,
but I have to deal it very
smoothly, very tenderly.
And then we found,
I didn't want her, but she was crying.
She was like,
because my Portuguese back then,
my Portuguese was not good,
but I was doing my
masters in 2012 and '14.
I came from Belgium then to do this.
That it was, because what I try to do
is I tried to let them know myself
and explore like, okay, there
is a universal language,
there is
a kind of unwritten bond
between filmmaker and the character,
especially when you are
doing a creative documentary.
If the character,
if the people who we are filming,
if they have some confusion,
if they don't trust you,
you would never get proper,
you would never get a genuine story.
and you would never be possible.
It's impossible to make a
good film in terms of that.
So the trauma is always
like when we deal this pain,
and normally my films comes from pain,
my films mostly like tragedy, loss, pain,
and all this kind of work is, I don't know
how I go with this kind of film
and I get inspired and I make it.
And so with this grandma,
I just gave her a situation to unfold,
to reveal what's really her universe is.
And then she started revealing naturally
without just asking how
your husband got killed
and how your loss happened.
Were you very sad?
And, no, I didn't ask anything.
I just let her talk.
And all those people when I was
filming in the refugee camp,
I just said, "How are
you? How is your day?
How do you feel?
What are you thinking?"
So it started from very a simple question.
And then it linked with something else.
And then when it comes out and
either they smile or they cry
or they're just normal.
And there is one woman,
she was pregnant
and then I put in one version of the film.
She was pregnant and I was
asking her, "What are you doing?"
She asked me to film her
and her child inside her.
And she said, "Are you excited?"
Yes, I'm excited."
"And where is her his father?"
"He was slaughtered."
So the way she was
responding is like telling
that she had a breakfast or something.
You know how these people,
this mental trauma,
this loss, this tragedy made these people
like this level of like, kind
of, they lost everything.
They're no more human.
They're not sick, but they're
live in different level
of, I can't explain
properly with my words,
but for me, the film is
good to explain the things.
And then this is how I normally handle,
and sorry that I can read the acting.
- Yeah, no, it was really about
this balancing act that you
have to make as a filmmaker
between telling the story
and sort of figuring the trauma
when people are telling you the story.
- Yes.
Then we go with the,
like when we have food, what we see.
We don't go for everything
at the same time.
We choose our choice, our taste.
So in the same thing, if I could put,
I could put all kind of injury
wounds and more suffering,
more things, it would not
be accepted as it is now.
- [Neela] Yeah.
- It would not touch a big community.
It would not touch like,
okay, this is maybe.
Maybe it could touch, but then it's like
you will understand, okay,
this filmmaker is just
trying to make me sad.
- Yeah.
- But that's not my view.
That's not what I'm trying to do.
- And I do want to add one more thing,
which is I think that,
we need to make sure that
we treat people's responses
in the situation as precious, right?
And that's why it's important
that you've taken the trouble
to build that trust.
You talked about trust which
takes a long time to build
and ask them questions,
very vulnerable questions.
And it's our responsibility
then to share it
as widely as possible
so we don't have 50 people all descending
on the camp with the same idea
and keeping on asking the same questions
over and over again.
I think that if we have
people who are going in
and who are sort of building trust
with the communities there
and who are asking these
questions and getting responses,
I think we should.
Our responsibilities to
share that information
as much as possible.
And I do wanna say,
for example, at Y-RISE,
I mentioned this a little bit,
but we are doing some
research collecting data
around consumption and among other things
and starting out with things like,
what is the extent of
violence against women?
But also maybe looking at
other questions and so on.
And one of the things we want to do
is we are gonna be in the
data collection process
in October, November,
have the data early next year
and share that data widely
so that we don't have a
constant stream of researchers
who are going in there and saying,
"Oh, I must ask my question
because this is a particular case
where you can't keep
asking people 100 times
over and over again.
It's not just that people will get tired,
it's also that people
don't want to keep talking
about the trauma over and over again.
So we should be respectful and
I think one of our big duties
is to make sure that we are
not duplicating research
or storytelling so that we are
respectful of people's sort
of time and what they're going through
when they provide answers
to these questions.
So I'm glad you mentioned trust.
It's a very long process
and we just wanna make sure
that others don't do that.
And that was a wonderful story about...
Very sad about the
Portuguese lady as well.
So I guess you probably have
some expertise I wanna say
or some experience in these situations.
And again, I think the other
main lesson I'm getting
from you is, in these
difficult situations,
it's always good to have
somebody who has experience
in these situations.
I think if we just go in as
just researchers or filmmakers
who don't know anything
about the situation,
never worked in similar situations,
we are likely to cause
more harm than to do good.
So I think it's worth it
for us to actually think
about that.
But I echo CC who said
that I learned so much
from Sohel and the Rohingya people.
I did too just watching this documentary
for an hour and 15 minutes.
I think I learned more
than reading everything
and it really sank in
in a way that I can read
any news article or whatever proclamation,
but this really brings it home.
And also to thank you for the chance.
Let us witness the stories.
I'm going to actually just
call on Teresa Delgado,
who's the Head of the
Refugee Program at McMillan
to say a few words because
I think this is thanks to.
It was organized through the program,
the Refugee Program at McMillan.
And this is one of the many
things that the center does.
So, Teresa, if I can have
you just say a few words
and then I'll close this.
And thank you so much too.
I hope I have answered.
If I haven't answered any
or Sohel hasn't answered
any audience questions,
or you haven't had a chance to ask him,
can you re-just-copy it so that I know
that we haven't answered it?
But I think we have gone through all
and thank you for being
such an engaged audience.
Teresa.
- Yeah, no, I just want
as well to thank everybody
for participating in this session.
And for us, we see the role that we have
as mainly sort of given the opportunity
to people to see
and share the experiences of others,
of the refugee, of
people who have no voice.
So actually we see this as a platform.
And given that we are here at Yale,
I think our role is just to,
I mean, engage with programs
as well as like the Y-RISE
in terms of the research
that can be done,
but balancing also with the
other type of dissemination,
let's say, of showing, I
mean all of the, what Sohel
was talking about, the empathy, I guess,
in order to relate to the refugees
and give them the rights
that have been taken aback.
So hope you can continue to
participate and to watch
the seminars and films.
And if you have any suggestions,
please do write to us.
Thank you.
Okay.
- Thank you.
Thank you, Teresa.
I think the Program on
Refugees does a huge job
in terms of making these
stories accessible.
And I agree with you.
I think that the stories that Sohel
and other filmmakers and
storytellers talk about
is just as valuable when we say data
as the kind of hard data
or quantitative data
that we might do as an
academic research center.
I think if you want to move people,
you've got to show them
not just the numbers,
but also the stories of people's lives.
So I think this is fantastic.
And to those on today
who are present today,
I think there's a link to see the film.
We'd request that you not
share it widely right now
because I think it's still being shown.
But, yes, we hope that you
do have a chance to catch up
with this fantastic film.
So thank you to everyone,
to the Yale MacMillan
Center Program on Refugees
for bringing this before Sohel,
of course for the courage and the patience
and it requires the resilience
and most of all, of course,
if you ever get a chance
to speak with the children
and with others in the camp
to tell them like how moved
we were by the stories and
to wish them well actually.